Charles sauvage a purgé 20 ans de sa
condamnation à vie dans la prison
centrale de Katmandou n'est pas
citoyen français d'origine vietnamienne
et indienne sauvage a commencé à
parcourir le monde au début des années
70 comme étant ici et là des petits
délits en 1975 il se retrouve dans la
capitale thaïlandaise Bangkok avec son
ami canadienne Marie-Andrée Leclerc
rencontré quelques mois plus tôt en Inde
ce faisant passer pour un négociant en
pierre précieuse il se lit et d'amitié
avec ses victimes souvent des routards
occidentaux sur la piste des hippies des
années 1970 avant de les droguer de les
voler et de les assassiner
l'habilité du tueur a disparaître lui
vaut d’être surnommé le serpent ce sera
le titre d'une mini série que la BBC
consacrera sobrages avant d'être diffusé
sur Netflix en 2021 le criminel étant
incarné par l'acteur français d'arrahim
les amis sont toujours les bienvenus à
la maison la série est basée sur le
livre de journalistes australien qui le
décrivent comme froid et arrogant et en
même temps fascinant il méprisait ses
victimes qui lui vouaient une confiance
totale et il se voyait en héros criminel
le couple est arrêté en Inde 1976 où il
sera condamné à la prison à perpétuité
le sort de sa compagne Marie-Andrée
Leclerc a retenu l'attention de tout le
Québec victime ou complices un instant
qu’elle interviewé moi je pense que il y
a pas doute qu'elle était complice mais
complice elle a tout le temps ni ça mais
comment peut-on vivre comme à la vécu
voir ce qui se passait dans
l'appartement elle vivait avec lui sans
se rendre compte que il y avait des
c'est presque pas croyable atteinte d'un
cancer Marie-Andrée Leclerc rentre chez
elle en 1983
[Musique]
salée en fait ce que je vis actuellement
c'est difficile moi dans un an je serai
peut-être dans ma tombe Marie-Andrée
Leclerc décède l'année suivante sobra
j'ai libéré en 1997 puis arrêter de
nouveau Népal en 2003 où il sera
condamné à nouveau pour le meurtre d'une
touriste américaine en 1975 dans ce pays
tant d'années plus tard l'histoire
fascine encore
de personnages là qui ont deux visages
qui ont de vie le serpent doit être
opéré du cœur il sera expulsé du Népal
dans les 15 jours Jean-Michel le prince
Ray du Canada Montréal